hello everyone and welcome to this talk
thank you so much for being here I know
there's so many different other
presentations out there so my name is
Marsha I am a data scientist I work as a
consultant at booba I'm originally from
Croatia and at my free time I am a
full-time geek doing cosplay at science
fiction conventions and stuff so that's
all to know about me now let's talk
about my text summarization so today our
agenda for today is basically first
we're going to discuss a little bit okay
what is automatic text summarization and
why is it used and what are different
types of text summarization then we will
discuss some methods and algorithms that
are used today to summarize and that we
used in the past to summarize text
automatically and in the end we are
going to discuss some of the evaluation
methods so how to know if our summaries
are good enough now text summarization
is a very very broad area so there are
many different methods many different
algorithms there is many ways to
evaluate your text summarization
different types of summarization so of
course there is not enough time in one
hour to go through all of that so you
know we're gonna kind of try to
summarize our summers how to summarize
so first part is we talk will be what is
automatic text summarization basically
text summarization in general is the
process of shortening a text document in
order to create a summary with the major
points of the original document now
automatic text summarization is the same
thing but just instead of having manual
manually created summaries we are using
software now there are many reasons to
create summary but first and foremost
the main reason is that we have more and
more text data and less and less time to
process it so today I mean even before
we had a lot of text data even when the
text data was mostly written on a paper
however today with all the
digitalization and with the internet
being the endless source of the text
data we are kind of flooded with the
textual information and it's really hard
to find relevant information
in all this amount of text so why would
need summaries well one one use case
would be if really we don't have time to
read the entire document then it would
be great to have some automatic
automated way to actually create
summaries so that people can just read
the summary and get the information they
need on the other hand sometimes that is
not enough sometimes you do need you
need to go into details and you don't
need to read an entire document but it
could be very useful to have a summary
of the document so you can read it and
see okay is this document actually
relevant for me is this something that
does does this document actually contain
the information I'm looking for now the
problems we're dealing with in any kind
of summarization both manual and
automatic is well first how do we select
the most relevant information from a
source document and then once we have
this information how do we express it in
this final summary so the objective of
any summarizer is to write a program
visit our objective is to write a
program that can reduce the size of a
text while preserving all the main
points of its meaning so how to say the
most important things in the shortest
amount of time and what we're trying to
do with any summarizes what our goals
are well first of all we want to
optimize topic coverage and we want to
optimize readability so does the summary
incorporate all the main topics from the
document and thus the summary sentence
flows in some kind of logical way so can
we actually read it and understand it
now there are different types of text
summarization and one of the one way we
can look at the different types is based
on the input type so when we think about
text summarization or based on the input
type there are two types we have single
document or multi document
classification basically it's self
explanatory in one way we have only one
document that we're trying to summarize
in this other one we have multiple
documents and the final summary should
contain information from all of these
documents now there is also
Division of text summarization based on
context and here we have domain-specific
generic and query based summaries so in
domain-specific summaries what we are
actually so we are using some domain
knowledge so what that means that means
that if you have some specific arts on
specific text you're trying to summarize
for example you're summarizing the
scientific article in biomedicine maybe
you do have enough domain knowledge that
you can incorporate in your model so
that because as some domain expert in
biomedicine maybe you know which which
words could be the most important and
which ones are maybe not relevant for
the summarization and you don't want
them ending up in the final summary now
query-based
here those are the type of summer is
when the summaries kind of only contain
the information about this that answers
this natural language question you about
the text so those are for example those
type of summaries you know when you're
like searching for something on Google
and then you get research results and
those search results are basically the
website for what you're searching for
but there is also a little paragraph
down underneath it that has actually all
the words that are the most important
all the most important sentences from
that website that are actually related
to your search query and of course there
are these generic summaries where our
model does not make any special
assumptions about the domain or about
the type of content of text or the type
of information you need to get and the
generic summaries are basically the one
where the majority of work has been done
now probably the most important two
types of text summarization are actually
based on the output type now those are
extractive and abstractive summaries so
extractive summaries are actually
summaries where the important sentences
are extracted from text so we just look
into the text and then we find the most
important sentences of the text and then
we extract them and then we actually and
then those sentences are what makes our
summary so something like this on the
other hand this is
something how our human would actually
write summaries right so when we write
summaries we actually read the text and
then we if I tell you summarize a book
you will not give me the most important
sentences of a book right you will read
the book and you're gonna give me a
summary using your own words so you're
gonna be using some terms and some words
that are not appearing in the original
document so this is what extractive
summary this is the difference between
extractive and obstructive summaries now
if we try to take a closer look at these
things so extractive summaries how they
work well as I said we have some text
for example Wikipedia article about Game
of Thrones and we want to create a
summary of this right so what we do with
extracted summaries as I said already we
just select the most important sentences
let's say those are these four or three
and a half so you can see here that you
know we are extremists of the time in
extracted summaries we are extracting
entire sentences so most of the time but
sometimes you would also maybe wanted to
extract just piece of sentences that has
the most information so for example in
this second sentence I don't think it is
important that first book of A Song of
Ice and Fire is actually Game of Thrones
so I have ignored that information now
one great thing about this extractive
summaries is that you don't really have
to worry about grammar because if the
sentence in the original article was
grammatically correct and you're just
extracting that sentence of course the
sentence is going to be grammatically
correct in the summary as well however
there could be some issues with
extractive summaries and one of the most
important was is the lack of balance
what can happen sometimes with the
extracted summaries let's say you have a
document that consists of two topics for
example even in this case we have this
perverse paragraph that is talking about
the production of The Game of Thrones TV
show right where it was filmed how many
seasons it had what it was based on who
created it and so on however on this
other part we actually have another
completely different topic that is
talking about
the story okay so what are the story
arcs what are the plots in the game of
Thrones so what could happen is that if
you are just extracting and most
important sentences you could end up
with summary that contains only
sentences from the first paragraph and
or only sentences from the second
paragraph so and we said that you know
topic coverage is one of the main goals
we want to optimize topic coverage and
here we're not doing it
so arson in this case our summary is
definitely not balanced another problem
that can happen is something that's
called lack of cohesion so lack of
cohesion actually means this let's say I
have extracted three sentences from this
thing so now first one is great we know
what Game of Thrones is second one says
that filming location also include
Canada Croatia Iceland blah blah now
this okay kind of we can read it we can
make sense doesn't make sense because it
says also including so there should be
obviously there is part of information
missing from before but this third
sentence just by reading Golda's or in
sentences makes no sense at all because
in one sentence we're talking about will
be filming and then the other one is
talking about this ruling dynasty
returning to the throne fears people's
creatures from the north and we have no
idea what that is all about and this is
one of the most common problems that you
can encounter with any kind of
extractive text summarization on the
other hand abstractive summary well
obstructive summary is much more similar
to the way humans summarize right so
when we summarize as I said already we
don't just extract sentences our brain
looks differently we create our brain
creates this internal semantic
representation of a text that we just
read and then we eat from that we
actually generate summary using our own
words so this was for example the
summary I created from Game of Thrones
article now as you can see here I am
using new words so instead of saying
that American that Game of Thrones is
American fantasy drama television series
I'm saying it's a TV show
right so I'm
using the words that are not appearing
in the original article now this this is
actually this this abstract
summarization is what we would like to
accomplish when when we're in the end so
the angle with the automatic test
summarization we would like to get
something like this right however this
is quite difficult techniques that we
have to use for this are quite advanced
if we want to do any kind of abstracted
summarization we have to go with some
very very advanced
deep learning models and even those are
not giving us yet at least
like very super-awesome results in all
of the scenarios because as you can see
here there is a lot of domain knowledge
that we have to have when we're doing
abstracted summary so you know for
example here I'm saying that it was
filmed across three different continents
now for us that of course sounds like a
common sense everyone knows where these
countries are however that is in the end
the domain knowledge about geography if
I haven't had that knowledge where
Morocco is and Canada and so on I
wouldn't have known how to formulate
this in the short way so that I can
still give you the information about
that there were multiple countries
involved so because of that the
extraction methods are still ones that
are mostly used even though they do not
work as as we would like it in the end
so now we can go through some of the
methods that were used or are used today
for automated the automatic text
summarization so first method ever used
for automatic text summarization was
something called positional method and
positional method was actually
introduced in 1959 so 60 years ago so
this is not really a new thing you know
people have been researching this for a
while and so this Baxendale he published
an article where he was actually
analyzing 200 paragraphs from the
scientific documents what
trying to find he what he was trying to
do is he was trying to okay to the topic
sentences those are the sentences that
are most related to the main topic of
the article and what he found out after
analyzing these 200 paragraphs is that
in 85% of the cases topic sentence was
the first sentence in the paragraph and
in the 7 percent of the cases topic
sentence was actually the last sentence
in the paragraph so this is basically
how the positional method works you have
a paragraph and you just take first
sentence and last sentence of the
paragraph and you take extract that as
your summary quite simple right so this
yes was very simple and very naive
approach but it was actually quite
reasonable at least for the for the type
of the documents that he was trying to
summarize it turned out that it was
actually working just fine and we are
not doing this method anymore however
this was the first paper in automatic
text summarization and a lot of works
added that followed were actually kind
of using this technique as a starting
point now the same year in 1959 Lauren
actually came with a little bit more
advanced method now what he was walking
into his he was actually introducing the
concept called frequency of content
terms which basically means frequency of
words right so he analyzed okay how
often the words appear in the document
and then this is actually a chart from
his original article what he saw is that
he was trying to find significant words
and what he saw was that okay those
words that appeared the most and those
words that appeared the least in the
article are not significant so we can
kind of remove them and not worry about
them and the significant words were
actually in this interval of in the like
the middle range of the frequencies of
the words and he was also the first one
to start with some data pre-processing
before doing any kind of automatic
summarization so he was removing
supports because if you think about it
this
most common words that's actually the
definition of a stop word and he was
also using stemming so he was dropping
off the suffixes of the world in order
to get to the root form of a word so
that machine knows that cat and cats are
basically the same thing that they're
referring to the same animal
so how his method worked well it was
very simple the whole idea was about
selecting sentences with highest
concentration of salient content terms
which again means just select sentences
with most of the important words in them
so if we have a sentence that has ten
words and let's say four of them are
significant words so four of them are in
that middle range of that chart one idea
here would be okay how to then say how
important is this sentence well we could
just divide number of significant words
with number of old words so 4/10 which
we would say ok score is 0.4 however he
did something a bit more complex
what he did was instead of dividing with
the number of all words in the sentence
he was actually dividing with the length
of the span in which they appear so
basically in this case so he was just
counting how many words are between
first and the last significant word so
in this case then he made this formula
for the score which was again quite
basic so number of all significant words
squared divided by number of all words
or all words in the spec in the span and
as you can see this is actually a very
reasonable matrix especially for
you-know-who 60 years ago because it
does take into consideration two very
important things in the document
summarization first one being important
words and the second one being that they
are highly concentrated next to each
other because we don't want them to be
dispersed all over the document now 10
years later in 1968 Edmondson came up
with a new method so he was actually
using some of the old already mentioned
features so he was using position of the
sentence
in a document the same way as back salad
and he was also looking at the word
frequency the same as loon but what he
added was something called cue words now
these key words are manually selected
words that are highly correlated with
the importance of sentences and there
are three types of cue words there are
bonus words that are pointing to the
important sentence there are stigma
words they on the other hand have
negative effect on the sentence
importance so most likely those are the
words that you would expect that machine
will treat as important but they're
really not and there are also no words
which are neutral or irrelevant to the
importance of the sentence so they're
kind of like a stop words so you can
just like ignore them when doing the
summarization another thing he was
looking into was the document structure
so is this sentence our headline is it
the title is it the first sentence right
under the title and so on and then as
the score for each sentence he created
some kind of linear combination of these
four P features and this is one of the
algorithms that is still used and
changing these few words actually can
change a lot the performance of your
Samuraizer so actually if you know that
you can select that you have enough
domain knowledge to actually select
proper keywords here you can get very
good results however it does require a
lot of domain knowledge in order to do
so now the next thing is completely
different approach that was done by
because this is all more like
statistical thing however the completely
different approach was done by this room
in 1979 he created a program a
Samuraizer called from and this was the
first knowledge based summarization
system it was this template feeling
approach so where it's trying to all
these template feeling approaches are
basically trying to obtain some
predefined types of information that is
specified in the slots of the template
and they're using some kind of
information
extract extraction methods so each slot
in the template represent one part of
the salient information that we should
take from the text and so he created
like this collection of some 50
so-called sketchy scripts and they
correspond to the different situation
that are often discussed in the news so
each of these sketchy scripts then had
this kind of like a formula that
contained like each of these lines their
slots were actually containing important
events that we expect to occur in a
specific situation and then summarizer
tries to read through the article and
find those specific situation and fill
up the holes in the actual script and so
this is for example one of the scripts
it was demonstration script and so it
goes like it starts with the
demonstrators arrive at the location
they march they arrive police arrives
then demonstrators communicate with the
target of demonstration then they attack
the target then they attack the police
and then in the end police arrest them
so you can see that this is a fairly
specific scenario and when this happens
you know in an actual when you have a
demonstration well it may happen just
like this and then you can actually fill
up these holes quite well reading the
article however once he tried to
evaluate his summarizer he realized that
50 scratch scripts are just not enough
to cover all the possible topics that
you can find in the news so then he so
he basically then realized that either
he would have to do some more or you
know just go with something else now it
was basically all in 1995 when people
started to use like a proper machine
learning techniques for the four
automatic text summarization and so
first one of them was qpm who was
actually using the first trainable
method
so he was trying to use cause he was
using classification to create summary
now classification is a supervised
machine learning problem so in order to
do any classification we need to have a
good training data set we need to have
some label data so what he had this he
had a list of about I think it was 180
something documents and he also had
manually created extracts meaning that
he had people select sentences from
these articles and then he of course did
some data pre-processing and then he was
actually tagging each of the sentence
labeling it wit so in on one document so
each sentence was labeled with one if
the sentence ended up in a manually
created extract and 0 if that sentence
was not there so then he actually
created a training dataset that he could
use to create a classification model and
to make predictions on the new data for
that he used naive Bayes classifier
which is basically working on the naive
on the bias and formula which tells you
that the probability that the sentence s
belongs to the summary given that it has
some set of features is the same as the
probability that these features occurs
if the sentences in summary times
probability that the sentence is a
summary divided by the probability that
these features are occurred together
right and then since here we can
actually assume statistical independence
of the feature we can make it a little
bit less simple so we can actually see
here that what it really says is that
probability that some that sentence ends
up in a summary given certain set of
features is basically the product of the
probability of the individual features
that appear for the sentences that
appear in the summary and his model was
actually performing quite well so for he
was taking 25 percent extracts and he
was getting a precision of 84 and for
smaller summaries he even got a 74%
improvement over elite summaries where
lis summaries are the summaries where
you just extract first couple of
sentence
is from the text and this was a method
that was used quite long it was giving
okay results however in 2002 Miles
Osbourne actually published a paper
where he showed that there could be
better models for classification of
these sentences then naive bias so he
actually saw that these maximum entropy
models are performing better because he
actually he realized that those features
are not really independent like so the
the probability that you know the
position of the sentence maybe and the
number of stop words in the sentence and
all the different features you can use
most likely are not independent with one
another so then we can use other
approaches now one of the problems that
can happen when you're working with the
text summarization is that what if you
have is especially when you're working
with the text summarization from
different documents what if you have the
sentences that are talking more or less
about the same thing in that case if
those sentences contain some very they
both are gonna contain a lot of
information and they're gonna both get
high score based on any kind of metrics
you're using so what happens then and in
1998 there was a metrics called maximum
marginal reference that was introduced
now this one was used for query based
summaries so but there are other methods
very similar to this one that re then
you can use for generic summaries and so
on however this was one of the first
methods and what it actually says here
how the this method actually works is
that we have so we have a user query and
we also have some kind of similarity
metrics which we defined ourselves and
then the what we want actually so here
we're taking into consideration both how
similar the sentence or the document you
know this is also for the information
retrieval documents the same thing so
how similar is the sentence to the
actual query
but also we're taking into consideration
okay how similar is the sentence to the
sentences that were already extracted to
the summary because if we have two
sentences that are you know more or less
of the same importance and more or less
talking about the same thing then if I
give you to read first sentence and then
I give you the read second sentence then
marginal value of the second sentence is
actually very low because you already
have that information so instead of that
we want some sentence that maybe has a
higher lower well value but is still
contributing with the information to the
actual summary okay so one other
approach was meat which was introduced
in 2000 in 2000 and this was actually
our centroid based method so it was
working both for single and multi
documents so how this method works
basically we let's say we have some
sentences again from the different
documents and then we represent these
sentences in some vector space as dots
in some vector space okay so now one
thing first thing we want to do is we
want to cluster them into some topics so
here we can see that we kind of have two
clusters of sentences talking probably
about two different topics and what we
first try to find is these centroids so
centroids are centers of the mass of
individual clusters so these are our
centroids and then we actually select
the sentences that are the closest to
the Centers of the topic and of course
in this case again especially for
dealing with multi document
summarization there is that problem that
we mentioned before now about maybe
we'll get the two of the same sentences
so again here we are going to be doing
some rewriting methods using summary
ranking matrix to actually select the
sentences that are the closest to the
centroids but also different from one
another
now there has also been a lot of these
graph based methods throughout the years
and one of them is a method called lacks
rank so this is a graph based method
that was introduced in 2004 and the
whole idea behind it is something called
lexical centrality so how this method
works well so we have some document or
multiple amount of documents and then we
create something called similarity
matrix where basically we are looking
into okay how similar are each two
sentences in the document or in the
corpus of documents to one another and
then we actually represent each
sentences as the nodes in the graph and
then we're looking into okay which
sentences are connected so because then
if the sentences have a lot of
similarity a lot of for example similar
words or something then they're going to
have a high value in the similarity
graph so this is an example from the
original article and so here we have 11
sentences from five different documents
that are talking about the same thing
right so and about the same event so
here for example D 2 s 3 means this is
the third sentence from the second
document so as I said we start with
building this similarity matrix and now
this similarity can be either cosine
similarity Jaccard similarity whatever
similarity you you decided to use so we
look into ok how similar are our
sentences so obviously all the elements
at the diagonal here one because they're
citizen one are the same but we are also
very interested in those sentences where
these similarities are as high as
possible so now we represent each
sentence as a node and then we are
looking into okay are they connected and
how are they connected and
we actually look into different
thresholds so the sentence is d 5 s 1
and D 5 s 3 they have this really thick
black line so the same as D 1 s 1 and D
2 s 1 so those are the two sentences
that in our similarity matrix actually
have the highest cord
so the they have 0.45 and 0.38 so this
is what happens so these two are
basically the only Connection we have if
we put a threshold to 0.3 now the more
we're lowering the threshold as you can
see here the more connections we get so
the main idea is basically to have if
the sentence is connected to many of the
sentences that means that one sentence
is similar to many of the sentences that
is one of the sentence that we should
consider to put into our final summary
and so basically the whole idea about
this is that kind of one sentence
recommends the other similar sentences
to the reader so if so if it's very
similar it would be of great importance
but also importance of the sentence is
coming from the importance of the
sentences that are recommending it so
this does sound a lot like a PageRank
algorithm that's used by Google and it
is working on the same principle and
there is also another very very similar
method called text rank and it's working
more or less the same there were just
two different methods that were created
approximately at the same time but two
different groups of people and they have
small differences for example text rank
is used mostly for single document
summarization while x rank is used
mostly for multi document summarization
also the similarity matrix used for the
similarity made matrix are slightly
different but in the end it is the same
approach and the same formula now if you
remember so far we were I mean we're
mostly talking about extractive packs
some
summarization method and as I said you
know we will be focusing on this more
because they are easier and we did have
a little bit of kind of obstructive
method because with from because from
foes like a slot filling knowledge-based
summarizer
and you know by the definition of
obstructive Samuraizer from was
extractive because it was the final
summarizer was actually using the words
that don't appear in the original
document and those were the words that
were like between those slots that were
needed to fill so it was kind of very
basic type of abstractive Samuraizer
however most of these abstract
summarizes are quite complex and in
order to do them in order to actually
work with them what we need is we need
some deep learning knowledge right so
the the most commonly used method for
obstructive text summarization is the
sequence to sequence method which is a
deep learning technique that was
introduced by Google team in 2014 so it
is called sequence to sequence because
it takes sequence as an output and it
also has a text sequence is an input and
it also giving us sequence as an output
and this is what we need for working
with you know text data because text is
actually nothing but a sequence of words
and one of the important thing in the
sequence is it's super important to know
where things are where words are so the
word what word 2ds depending on the word
one when we're making a sentence as
humans and we want the same thing from
the machines so just a quick overview of
how this goes I will not go into details
here but basically here we have an
original document so each of these
inputs are just set words in our
original document so we put that as an
input in our model now the model itself
consists of three parts first we have an
encoder part then we have some middle
part called encoder vector and then we
have the
decoder part so first we're in coding
and then we have to decode what we
encode it in the previous step so this
encoder part that's basically first one
is basically a stack of several
recurrent units that are that each each
of them accepts one element one input
element so one word and then what this
then each of them actually collects
information for its input from its input
so from one word and then propagates it
further on to the next recurrent unit
the the output of this encoder part is
actually the encoder vector now we can
treat we can think of this encoder
vector as being like the last hidden
state of the encoder part of the model
now encoder vector itself basically it
aims to encapsulate all the information
for all the input elements in order to
help the decoder make accurate
predictions and create the final summary
and encoder vector is then also acting
as the first hidden layer first first
hidden state of this decoder part of the
model now the coder network well that's
again here we have again several neural
neural dis these recurrent units and
each of them is actually predicting one
part of the output and then it also
propagates the knowledge to the next
recurrent unit and what you can see here
is that okay so first this first
recurrent unit is going to create output
one and then what goes into the second
one will be some you know hidden state
from the recurrent unit but also we're
taking into consideration the output one
when we're doing dealing when you're
trying to predict output two and that is
because you know once what is going to
be the second so a word in a sentence
depends on what is the first word in the
sentence and in the end finally we get
our summary so
this is just a quick overview of the
sequence the sequence method there's
much more going on out here
but it is and you know this is not the
only thing only way you can do the
automatic abstractive summarization
there are other methods and you can also
use the reinforcement learning and all
kind of different things so this is an
area that's improving everyday so new
algorithms are coming and I'm pretty
sure it's gonna get much much better
with time now the last part of this talk
is about evaluation so now we know how
to create these summaries but are they
good
how how good they are basically so what
makes a good summary so as I said before
we have two goals with summaries we want
to optimize the topic coverage and we
want to optimize readability and we can
look into different evaluation criteria
for this so for example one of them
being salience are we capturing the
salient the most important information
of the document length is the summary of
a proper length is it we don't want it
to be too short we don't want it to be
too long what about the structure is
structured well is it coherent can we
actually read it
are there some weird pronouns that are
happening or referring to the other
things is it balanced are we covering
all the topics from the original
document what about the grammar is it
grammatically correct and also is it non
redundant are there still may be some
parts of the samurai summary that we
could exclude and still get the complete
information and now one of the things we
would like to see here is we want to
optimize this information content
basically what we want is to optimize
the compression and retention ratio
where compression ratio is just telling
us okay what is the percentage of the
original document that ended up in the
summary and retention ratio is telling
us okay what is the percentage of
information of the original document
that was preserved in the summary and so
obviously we want to say as much as
possible in the shortest amount of time
so obviously we want to have very low
compare
high-compression arey a very low
compression ratio and very high
retention ratio so we want to have as
much information possible in the
shortest amount in the shortest number
of words now there are two different
methods to evaluate these models actrice
clinics those are the ones that are task
based and those are probably the better
ones to actually evaluate the models
however they do require a lot of manual
work so how they work can you have a
group of users and you divide their
users into two groups one group you give
a complete document other group you give
a summary and you give them some tasks
maybe they can classify these documents
into a set of predefined classes maybe
they can try to cluster these documents
maybe they can try to maybe you can ask
them some questions about information in
documents so they have to retrieve that
information from the text now if the
group that has only read the summary can
actually make the same decision and and
have the same results in this task as
the group who has read the whole
document then you know that your
summaries are good because then somebody
can actually just read the summary and
get the whole information however that
does require a lot of time and a lot of
people to actually be part of your
little experiment so usually we are not
doing that we're focusing on some
intricate techniques that are basically
about comparing summaries against golden
standards so you have a summary created
by a human and now and then you create
the automatic summary from the same text
and then you compare okay how similar
they are how similar our automatic
summary summary is to the ideal summary
made by human so there are different
approaches to how to actually but
different metrics to calculate how good
our summaries are one of the basic ones
is precision and recall now if you've
been working with any machine learning
you've heard about these terms so let's
say we have a document that has ten
sentences and we are only trying to and
we say okay we
want to extract two sentences out of it
and we create an ideal human based
summary that's selecting sentence number
one and two now if we have two different
summarize errs let's say one automatic
summer is a one using one method and
maybe a samurai's of to using other
method so we want to say okay which one
of them is better now what we can do is
we can create something that's called
confusion matrix now confusion matrix is
looking into all the different pairs of
what can happen has the when machine
selected sentence and human not and so
on so this is what our confusion matrix
basically looks like so the true
positives in this matrix well that's
basically just the number of sentences
that both human and summarize have
selected true negatives are basically
those sentences that both human and
summarizer
did not select into into the summarizer
and then for example false negatives
those are the ones that our machine did
not select but human actually selected
so those are the ones that we said are
negative but they should be actually
positive and so on and for this we can
actually make two different match matrix
called precision and recall precision is
basically number of true positives
divided by number of false positives and
true positives so now what this means so
false positives and true positives those
are all the sentences that machine
things should go into the summary so
what this measure tells us is out of all
the sentences that machine selected how
many of them are actually correctly
selected how many of them humans
selected as well another method another
measure is recall and recall tells us on
the other hand okay so here we have true
positives plus false negatives so this
is out of all the sentences that humans
selected how many of them has machines
selected as well so in our case in this
case of this Samuraizer let's look into
some Samuraizer one obviously has a
perfect score so it has two true
positives and divided by two so the
score is one both precision Eric
all can go between zero and one and we
want to have them as high as possible
so since the summarizer one exactly
extracted the same things as human
obviously that's a very good Samuraizer
however summarizer too well true
positives is one and false positive
passed through positive is two so here
we have 0.5 and the same for recall so
it was only able to capture one sentence
that out of two that human did so in
this case we would definitely say okay
Samuraizer one is working much much
better than the summarizer two however
what is an ideal summary what if we had
two sentences that were talking about
the same thing and they were very
similar and even human had to struggle
okay maybe the sentence - and sentence
for our super similar giving the same
information and even human didn't ok
should I go select sentence two or four
so human decides okay I'm gonna go with
sentence two and then when creating this
summarizes we had maybe a different
reread a ranking may may like make
matrix so that we could then maybe
summarizer one beaker based on the
metrics select a sentence two and
summarize our two selected sentence for
so that's why may be a better method
than precision recall is called utility
so how utility works is that instead of
just having these so just having people
select the what are the two most
important sentences we also want them to
rank those sentences as well so we want
them to say okay what is the most
important sentence and then the second
most important so give all our sentences
some points so let's say that then human
have this ranking for these five
sentences so human says okay sentence
number one is the most important so
obviously is going to get number ten
points now sentence number two gets nine
points but sentence number four actually
gets eight points right they're very
similar and we maybe we could do go so
go the other way maybe it's another
human would do the other way did this
opposite now
in this case summarizer one actually he
gets 19 points because some reason one
selected first and second sentence so
first sentence ten plus second sentence
nine and summarize are two in this case
well it gets 18 points because it select
a sentence of a ten points and sentence
of eight points now you can see that
okay Samuraizer one is still performing
better however it's not that big of a
difference right because last time we
had from 0.5 to one that was a huge
difference in precision and recall over
here well it's just one point difference
so even if we go with Samuraizer - well
it won't be that big of a deal right is
still very very similar now another
problem is that you know who says what's
the ideal summary I was working on the
project where I was supposed to extract
I was supposed to create this extractive
summarization and I needed to evaluate
my Samuraizer as well and then I asked
couple of my colleagues if they can help
me with that so if I can because I
needed this ideal summary so that I can
compare with my models and I asked for
colleagues I gave them five different
articles to read and to extract and
sentences sometimes five sometimes ten
doesn't matter and once they get the
results back well first of all you know
I said like for one article give me five
sentences and then half of them gives me
six four and so on so machine at least
gives you the numbered sentences you
want right unlike humans but other
problem was that once I was comparing
the results from them there was not a
single article where two humans out of
four gave me the exact same sentence is
not a single one so sometimes I had a
bit of overlap but sometimes actually
have two people same article completely
different ten sentences and these were
small articles these were not like books
you know so you can kind of randomly
pick you know ten sentences so it was it
was really crazy how people consider
differently information and
happen was this you know through the
articles some information was mentioning
more than once and then one person
selects first time and the other person
selects it when it appears second time
and so on and so there is actually a
major correlative utility that is also
taking this into consideration so not
only looking into one ideal summary but
also looking into taking more summaries
from different people and trying to
compare them all and see okay how does
our summary actually work - given this
whole set of summaries and rush n is
actually the method that is like the
matrix that is also incorporating this
and this is probably the most important
matrix for evaluation of the automatic
summaries it is based on another matrix
called blue which is used in machine
translation now the difference between
the two of them is that you will get a
very high blue results if you actually
have a high precision so if your
summarises have high position then you
will get high blue however on the other
hand if you have a high recall you are
gonna get the high root results and the
high results are the what what we want
so actually in Rouge are Irish and our R
stands for
recall so how does this method works
well it is actually comparing the
automatic summary but in this case with
a set of reference summaries so not just
one and what is using its using the
Engram overlap between the documents so
Engram is basically just sets of words
so one gram is one word two gram is two
words three gram three words and so on
so this is what actually gives us then
the the ability to see okay how is this
working
given the whole corpus of different
summaries created by different people
and this is the formula for this and
basically it's it's very simple so it's
just a number of these engrams that are
appearing in both our automated summary
and
in all these summaries that were created
by humans divided by a number of engrams
that are appearing in all these
summaries that were created by in all
these reference summaries and there are
other there are other rouge methods so
for example rouge L which instead of
this Engram over like e overlap is
looking into the longest common sequence
between the automatic summary and
between the these different manual
summaries and many more another method
the last one I will be talking about
today is called pyramid method and this
is the method that is based on semantic
constant units and it is used for multi
document summarization mostly so what
are these actually these semantic
content units so here what we have let's
say we have four sentences from four
different documents now all these
sentences again are more or less the
same so Donald Trump won the
presidential election in 2016 in USA
this is what they're all talking about
so now obviously one of the things that
we don't want is extract all these four
sentences because they are giving us the
same information however these are just
sentence one sentence from each of the
articles now what we do here is we
create this units that then are kind of
parts of the information that appear in
multiple documents so in our case we
have this first semantic content unit
one which is in from information that
tells us that Donald Trump became
president of United States okay and it
has the weight of four because that is
the information that's appearing in all
four documents on the other hand the
second sentence this sentence a second
semantic content unit is telling us when
it happens so it happened in 2016 it
gets way three because actually the
thirds the third sentence the sentence
from our third document does not say
when it happened so we have only three
occurrences of this 2016
so then this semantic unit gets gets
weight of a tree and then we create this
kind of pyramid structure so in our case
since we have only four sentences from
four documents well we have more
sentences but there are only four
documents so we we are looking into okay
into weights of these semantic units so
obviously it doesn't even matter what
these documents are about you know they
could all be about Hillary Clinton so
but what is important obviously it is
important for all of those documents
this information about Donald Trump
because if it wasn't that information
will not be appearing in all four
documents so this is why since this is a
very important information we want this
information to be captured in the final
summary so we want to have one sentence
doesn't matter anyone we don't want all
four of them but we want at least we
want one of them to appear in our
document so we want somewhere to be read
the Donald Trump won the election in the
Latsis in 2060 so once we create our
summaries then we just look into the
summaries and check ok how many of these
semantic units they actually have so if
we have one summary that has one
semantic unit of weight for and two
semantic units of weight three so maybe
there was the third semantic unit that
was talking about I don't know Monica
Lewinsky doesn't matter so then this
summary gets the ten points based on the
weights on the other hand if we have
summary that looks like this summary
that has one semantic unit of the weight
for one of the way three and one of the
weight one so here we know that we have
eight so eight points so in this case
Samuraizer one is better than Samuraizer
two also if you get the summarizer that
have the same not in necessarily the
same amount of points because what you
want is to have those summarize if they
had most of the points on the top of the
pyramid because you don't want the
summarizer in this case if you get the
summarizer that has ten points but all
of them being of the weight of one well
the summarizer is not so good because
the more
important thing here the wait for is not
actually part of the summarizer so this
is we're very good net to actually you
know evaluate their summarizes and this
is work for multi document summarization
now I said already there are many
different methods many different
approaches many different valuation
methods you can use last thing I want to
mention are the tools so if you want to
get into this what tools should you be
using
well there's python python is way to go
tool for any kind of data science
projects these days especially for any
kind of natural language processing
problems and there is a very awesome
library called salmon that actually has
all these predefined functions so you
can see that some of them we mentioned
today some of them we haven't so there
is quite a big number of functions that
you can try out for most of them you
don't have to actually do any kind of
pre-processing it's all compact already
there you just select ok a lot of them
are actually working quite well with
other languages for example in region
because of just important regions top
words and you just go with it of course
it's not perfect but it's working quite
reasonably for some of them of course
you need to add some more do some more
tweaking of the data for example
Edmondson they still you still need to
add those keywords that are
domain-specific but as you can see here
there is one Samuraizer still there so
60 years ago and we're kind of still
using it and it's actually giving quite
reasonable results
so it is not as bad as we thought it
would be and of course i mean if you
want to do any kind of deep learning
models or stuff with the abstract
summarization I would definitely
recommend tensor fall because you have
to moralize have to use it for any kind
of deeper learning problems ok that was
all for me thank you all very much for
listening I hope you learned something
about the text summarization and I hope
it was interested and hopefully it will
also get you into going into more into
trying to okay trying to try it out
yourself really like the download Python
if you haven't had it already this
package also it everything is for free
so you can just try it out and create
your own at least extractive summarize
errs
something thank you very much any
questions